person Starship is a band that is rich
in Rock and Roll history and legendary
songs so they'll be at the star of the
desert Arena on Saturday and earlier I
spoke with members David Friedberg and
Kathy Richardson about the show
[Music]
David and Kathy how are you guys doing
thanks for joining the show oh great
thanks for having us yeah
love it well thank good being here we're
excited about that
yeah where are we right now
we're excited about you guys coming to
Las Vegas you're playing Prim this
weekend let's start with some history of
the band of course it started out as
Jefferson Airplane you have Grace Slick
is is on vocals I mean legendary songs
like white rabbit and somebody to love
and then David you joined the band in
1972 how has the ride been
uh oh it was great and then not so great
and then great again and then and then
great again I mean it's kind of been
like that
mostly you know
it has its ups and downs and and changes
and it was kind of like life so in 1974
the transition to Jefferson Starship
takes place and then David you write and
you guys released the song Jane it's a
it's a Smash Hit it still stands the
test of time but the song Jane is it
about somebody uh that you know is there
an actual Jane
Again Play it again
[Applause]
[Music]
it was written about an actual person
but then you know when you get into
songwriting some some things are better
or worse than true you know so
she's actually still there still there
her name isn't Jane she changed her name
to protect the into innocent or guilty
depending on how you look at it
and uh and and she's she's a really good
friend and and she's a wonderful person
actually
[Music]
We Built This City
so what can we expect at the show at a
prim this weekend an incredible set of
music that spans through many
generations you will play the great hits
and well-known songs of Jefferson
Airplane Jefferson Starship and Starship
um our drummer Donnie Baldwin was part
of all those hits we built this city
Sarah nothing's going to stop us now I
kind of